"Uncatchable", Alexandr Zhelanov
...
-Souleymane Bachir Diagne,
est-ce que vous diriez aujourd'hui
que la démocratie
en Afrique est plutôt
en train de reculer ?
-Malheureusement,
c'est un constat à faire.
-Oui ?
-L'Afrique semble avoir renoué,
par exemple, avec les coups d'Etat.
C'est la meilleure manifestation
possible
de ce recul démocratique.
En revanche,
il fut un temps où,
lorsqu'il y avait
un coup d'Etat quelque part,
le club des présidents africains
accueillait le nouveau venu
et, au fond, s'accomodait
parfaitement
du fait accompli.
Ce n'est plus le cas.
-Plus aujourd'hui ?
-Plus aujourd'hui.
Ca veut dire
que la démocratie
a reculé,
mais elle est encore
la boussole,
l'orientation générale
du continent.
-Alors, par exemple,
quand il y a eu
le coup d'Etat au Mali
ou au Burkina Faso,
il y a eu des réactions
dans la "sous-région",
l'Afrique de l'Ouest ?
-Oui, voilà.
-Des présidents ont manifesté
leur désaccord
avec ce qu'il se passait.
-Absolument, la CEDEAO...
Cette organisation
des Etats de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
s'est réunie,
a condamné le coup d'Etat,
a demandé à la junte
qui s'est mise en place
de donner très rapidement
des délais,
de fixer des délais,
pour retourner
à l'ordre constitutionnel.
Et donc, voilà le genre
de réaction qui montre
qu'en définitive,
l'exigence est
toujours celle-là.
C'est l'exigence
de démocratie.
-Il y a une exigence ?
La croyance en la démocratie,
ça existe encore,
-Ca existe.
-C'est remis en question.
Pas uniquement en Afrique,
d'ailleurs.
On le voit ailleurs.
-Oui, la démocratie a reculé
partout dans le monde.
Je crois que l'organisme
qui s'appelle V-Dem,
qui est un organisme
de réflexion,
qui prend la mesure
de la démocratie
et qui publie
des rapports annuels,
a bien constaté
que la démocratie avait reculé
partout dans le monde.
Deux tiers de l'humanité
vivent sous des régimes
qui ne sont pas
des régimes démocratiques.
C'est énorme,
c'est énorme.
Et ensuite, les régimes autoritaires
ne sont pas sur la défensive.
Il y a l'affirmation
qu'au fond,
si on juge les choses
par leur efficacité,
que l'efficacité serait
plutôt du côté
de ces régimes autoritaires.
Et donc ceci est
assez alarmant.
Ce qui est alarmant
également,
c'est que les jeunes
ne semblent plus adhérer
à cette valeur
de la démocratie.
Autrement dit,
ce qui est plus inquiétant
que les coups d'Etat eux-mêmes,
c'est que des jeunes
manifestent pour saluer
ces coups d'Etat
et puis,
manifestent avec des drapeaux
qui sont ceux d'un pays
dont on ne peut pas dire
qu'il soit véritablement
un pays démocratique.
Et cela est inquiétant.
-C'est inquiétant
pour l'avenir ?
-Oui. Si nous parlons
de la jeunesse,
la jeunesse africaine
en particulier, nous parlons
de l'avenir de ce continent.
-Quels sont les causes
et les fautifs ?
C'est des responsabilités
locales
ou est-ce qu'il y a aussi
des responsabilités exogènes,
étrangères ?
Je parle
pour le continent africain,
évidemment.
-Oui, alors il faut voir
une cause massive
pour au moins deux
des coups d'Etat
que nous avons à l'esprit,
vous et moi,
c'est-à-dire le Mali
et le Burkina Faso,
une cause massive
qui est l'insécurité dans le Sahel.
Le terrorisme, le djihadisme,
aujourd'hui dans le Sahel.
Le Mali a failli basculer
à un moment donné,
il y a eu intervention
de l'armée française,
comme nous le savons.
Le Burkina se trouve aussi
sous la menace
de terroristes.
L'Etat burkinabé
et l'Etat malien
ne contrôlent plus une grande partie
de leur territoire
et les coups d'Etat
ont été d'abord
des réponses
à cette situation :
l'insécurité.
Et donc, voilà une cause massive
dont il faut tenir compte
et qui explique un peu
le basculement de ces pays
dans des régimes autoritaires.
Voilà.
Maintenant,
l'idée selon laquelle
les jeunes, au fond,
ne donnent plus tellement
de valeur à la démocratie,
alors que ça a été
la grande conquête
de la fin des années 90,
lorsque le continent africain,
qu'on disait oublié de la démocratie
et des droits de l'homme,
a connu des transitions
démocratiques,
a connu des changements,
des alternances...
Ca, c'est le meilleur signe.
Quand le pouvoir en place
perd les élections
et que le président de la République
appelle son opposant en disant :
"Bravo, tu as gagné,
"Viens qu'on s'occupe
de la transition."
C'est la meilleure...
C'est le meilleur signe
de la démocratie.
En revanche, la situation
dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons maintenant,
c'est une situation où on dit :
"La démocratie, ça ne se mange pas."
Ceci est répété souvent.
L'idée derrière une phrase
comme celle-là,
c'est que la démocratie
aurait échoué
à assurer le développement,
à donner des emplois,
à faire sortir de la pauvreté.
Il est difficile de rappeler
une chose : ce n'était pas
la fonction de la démocratie,
de donner à manger.
La fonction de la démocratie,
c'était d'ouvrir des possibles,
de permettre
que les valeurs humaines
et tous les talents
s'expriment librement.
Et c'est de cela
qu'il s'agit maintenant.
Il s'agit
de convaincre de cela
et donc,
il y a un travail
d'éducation à la démocratie
qu'il faut mener.
C'est la meilleure réponse
qu'on puisse opposer
à ce scepticisme démocratique,
comme on pourrait l'appeler.
-Souleymane Bachir Diagne,
vous êtes sénégalais.
-Oui.
-Et le Sénégal...
fait figure de contre-exemple,
justement,
ou plutôt de bon exemple,
puisque le Sénégal est né...
La démocratie tripartite,
c'est au début 1974,
avec le président Senghor.
Après, ça s'est ouvert,
encore davantage.
Il y a une alternance
qui se fait,
même s'il y a
beaucoup de chahut,
de bruit...
-Il y a eu deux alternances.
-Oui.
Comment vous l'expliquer ?
Pourquoi au Sénégal,
ça a marché
mieux qu'ailleurs ?
-Oui, il faut déjà...
Le mot "exception" semble
un petit peu...
-Excessif ?
-Excessif, mais il faut l'utiliser.
Il faut se rappeler que le Sénégal
a une tradition démocratique
qui vient
d'encore plus loin.
Rappelons-nous que le Sénégal
était une colonie particulière
pendant la colonisation
puisque c'était une colonie
où il y avait quatre villes
qui étaient des villes,
des communes de plein exercice
comme on appelait cela.
Les habitants des villes
de Saint-Louis, de Dakar,
de Rufisque et de Gorée
étaient non pas des sujets français
mais des citoyens français.
-Ils ont envoyé des cahiers
de doléances aux Etats généraux.
et ils ont voté
et envoyé des députés
au Parlement français
depuis le 19e siècle.
C'est ainsi que Blaise Diagne,
Lamine-Guèye, Galandou Diouf
ont été des députés sénégalais
envoyés au Parlement français.
Donc, le Sénégal connaît
des élections depuis le 19e siècle.
-Il y a une culture de l'élection.
-Une culture de l'élection.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
d'ailleurs, lorsque Senghor,
imitant ce qui se passait
sur le continent,
a instauré le parti unique,
il n'a jamais voulu
l'appeler "parti unique".
Il a toujours dit :
"Non, c'est un parti unifié."
Il a unifié des tendances,
il a rassemblé
des partis différents.
Ca veut dire qu'il y avait
une sorte de gêne
devant la notion de parti unique
de la part de Senghor,
pour deux raisons.
C'est un homme
de la IVe République,
il a toujours connu la démocratie.
Deuxièmement,
le meilleur frein
à l'autoritarisme,
c'était Senghor lui-même.
Poète, philosophe,
il s'est interdit au fond
de partir en laissant
un pays qui aurait été...
un pays autoritaire
sous le régime
d'un seul parti.
Donc, il a instauré
ce multipartisme.
Donc ça,
c'est la tradition politique.
A côté de cela,
il faut regarder également
un caractère particulier
du Sénégal,
qui est la force
des confréries...
religieuses.
Les leaders,
les guides spirituels
de ces confréries
ont toujours
également veillé
à la paix sociale.
-C'est ça.
-L'un d'eux a comparé le rôle
des marabouts à celui des pompiers
en disant qu'ils sont toujours là
pour éteindre les incendies...
-POUR TEMPERER LES ARDEURS.
-Assurer
qu'il y a une paix sociale.
Et l'un dans l'autre,
tout cela établit une sorte
de contrat social
sur lequel
le Sénégal s'est bâti
et qui peut expliquer
pourquoi le Sénégal
a toujours gardé
cette orientation démocratique.
Vous l'avez rappelé,
il y a eu
des moments ou on a eu peur.
On a semblé marcher
au bord de l'abîme.
Mais au bout du compte,
cette exception
finit toujours
par triompher.
Et le Sénégal est un pays
qui pourrait avoir
la même devise
que la ville de Paris.
"Fluctuat nec mergitur".
Voilà.
-Alors, justement,
on parle de Senghor
qui est une figure majeure,
évidemment, du Sénégal,
le père de la nation,
on peut dire,
mais une figure majeure aussi
de la vie artistique,
politique
de l'ensemble du continent.
Mais on sent aujourd'hui
que toute la philosophie,
justement, politique
et artistique
de Senghor,
qui fait la promotion
de la négritude.
Mais la négritude,
pour lui,
c'est justement une affirmation,
mais une affirmation qui ne nie pas
les différences et tout ça.
On a le sentiment
qu'il y a une remise en question
chez les jeunes aujourd'hui
de, justement,
toute cette philosophie
qui dit : "Mais finalement,
Senghor, c'était
- permettez l'expression -
"un peu un collaborateur
du colon, quoi."
Vous êtes d'accord avec ça ?
-Alors, c'est vrai que Senghor
est une figure très controversée
de ce point de vue.
Il faut rappeler,
et vous avez bien fait de le dire,
que tout en étant,
avec Aimé Césaire
et Léon-Gontran Damas,
un des grands...
pionniers de la négritude,
l'affirmation des valeurs
de civilisation
du monde noir,
ainsi qu'ils définissaient
la négritude,
il est avant tout
un philosophe du métissage,
de la rencontre
et du dialogue des cultures.
Ceci était très important.
Au fond, une des affirmations
les plus importantes chez Senghor,
c'est que chacun doit être
métisse à sa façon.
Dans "doit être métisse",
le "doit" est important.
C'est un devoir éthique.
C'est une disposition éthique
au décentrement,
à la capacité de regarder
la perspective de l'autre, etc.
Ceci a défini
la personnalité de Senghor
et a défini également
pendant très longtemps
la philosophie politique
sur laquelle
le Sénégal a reposé.
En effet, Senghor a toujours estimé
qu'au bout du compte,
dans un monde
d'interdépendance,
il s'agissait de développer,
dans la paix,
la capacité de négociation
et dans le dialogue,
un pouvoir de négociation
de plus en plus important.
C'est un gradualiste
sur beaucoup de choses.
Il croyait énormément également
à l'unité africaine
et il estimait que ceci
se réaliserait graduellement
par cercles concentriques.
Et au fond,
cette philosophie-là,
qui a été la philosophie
sur laquelle
le Sénégal a été fondé
est, vous l'avez dit,
aujourd'hui remise en cause
par une jeunesse
qui est peut-être plus impatiente,
qui est plus...
bouillante,
d'une certaine façon.
-Cultive la cancel culture aussi.
Ce qu'on appelle
la philosophie woke,
c'est-à-dire le rejet de qui passé,
le passé colonial.
-Qui épouse
une philosophie de la rupture.
Et évidemment,
Senghor semble
être aux antipodes
de cette philosophie
de la rupture.
-C'est l'anti-wokisme, Senghor.
-Oui, de ce point de vue.
C'est quelqu'un qui appelait
à un dialogue des cultures.
Il a même écrit
que le colonialisme
était un mal,
mais que dans la mesure
où c'était un fait accompli,
il fallait en quelque sorte
profiter du fait
que le colonialisme
avait rapproché les peuples
et avait constitué une sorte
d'embryon de cosmopolitisme.
Et vous voyez,
c'est cette manière
qui était la sienne,
de regarder la totalité.
C'est un penseur de la totalité.
C'est un penseur
de son propre particularisme.
Quand on est penseur
de la totalité,
on a le sentiment
que le temps travaille
pour aller dans la bonne direction
et qu'il ne faut pas avoir
ces sortes d'impatience
et ce caractère révolutionnaire.
Ce n'était pas un révolutionnaire,
il était pour les réformes.
Il estimait que les réformes étaient
ce qui transformait graduellement,
et de manière apaisée, les sociétés.
-Je voudrais vous faire réagir
à deux phrases,
puisque vous êtes
un brillant exégète.
Une phrase qui a fait couler
énormément d'encre :
Quand il dit
que "l'émotion est nègre"
et que "la raison est hellène",
grecque en fait,
c'est terrible, comme citation.
-C'est une phrase qui a lui a été
énormément reprochée.
-Elle n'est pas apocryphe.
-Elle n'est pas apocryphe du tout.
C'est une phrase qu'il a écrite
dans un
de ses tout premiers articles
qui s'appelle
"Ce que l'homme Noir apporte".
Donc c'est très clair,
cette phrase ne lui est pas
simplement attribuée,
elle est de lui.
Simplement,
elle n'a pas été comprise.
Senghor n'a pas arrêté de répéter
qu'il était bergsonien
avant tout.
La première chose à faire,
c'était de voir
la signification qu'il donnait
à ce concept d'émotion.
Quand on sait que Bergson a fait
une distinction
entre ce qu'il a appelé
l'émotion créatrice,
c'est-à-dire la capacité
que nous avons d'être émus,
au sens étymologique
de "émotion",
un mouvement de sortie de soi
pour créer.
Senghor est un philosophe de l'art,
avant tout.
Sortir de soi pour créer,
c'est la signification
de l'émotion créatrice.
Et à cette émotion créatrice,
que Bergson appelait
"émotion supra-intellectuelle"...
Bergson opposait ce qu'il appelait
une émotion infra-intellectuelle,
qui était la simple réaction.
Quelque chose se passe,
et j'ai une réaction émotive
vis-à-vis de cette chose-là.
Une fois que l'on a rappelé
l'origine de ce mot,
de ce concept d'émotion,
et l'usage qu'en fait Senghor,
cette phrase apparaît
pour ce qu'elle est :
la capacité créatrice de l'émotion
est aux oeuvres artistiques
africaines
ce que l'approche rationnelle,
d'imitation de la nature,
est à la statuaire gréco-romaine.
Ca devient une analogie
tout à fait compréhensible,
dès lors qu'on en a fait l'exégèse,
c'est-à-dire qu'on a reconduit
les concepts utilisés par Senghor
à leur origine bergsonienne.
-La deuxième citation,
- qui est magnifique,
magnifique : -
"L'orgueil d'être différent
n'empêche pas
"le bonheur d'être ensemble."
C'est fabuleux, ça.
-Oui.
-On devrait enseigner ça partout.
-S'il y avait une formule
à retenir de Senghor,
cela devrait être celle-là.
"Mesurez", dit-il plus exactement.
"Mesurez l'orgueil d'être différent
"au bonheur d'être ensemble."
Et donc,
affirmer sa propre différence.
Affirmer que le monde
est pluriel,
que le monde
n'est pas uniforme,
qu'il est tissé
de toutes nos différences,
des différentes manières
que les cultures ont
d'exprimer l'aventure humaine.
Chaque culture donne
un visage particulier à l'humanité.
Ces visages, ensemble, composent
la symphonie du monde,
d'une certaine façon,
pour parler le langage de l'art
et de la musique.
Cette phrase-là
résume Senghor
et elle est encore mieux
que le couple
enracinement-ouverture,
qu'il emploie aussi à peu près
avec la même signification.
"Mesurer l'orgueil
d'être différent",
s'affirmer, défendre,
et illustrer
le visage que l'on offre
de l'humanité.
Mais en même temps,
se souvenir qu'il faut
que nous soyons tous ensemble,
que nous nous donnions
un horizon d'universalité,
un horizon qui repose
sur notre humanité partagée
et que cela est la tâche.
Ce message senghorien
s'adresse à nous, aujourd'hui.
-Alors, justement.
Vous parliez tout à l'heure
de l'exemple sénégalais
à propos de l'Islam,
en disant que c'était un islam
avec des repères :
les Tidjanes, les Mourides
et d'autres confréries,
qui permettent
la tempérance.
On a le sentiment,
et vous avez beaucoup écrit
là-dessus,
sur l'enfermement religieux,
l'enfermement nationaliste.
Est-ce que, d'une certaine façon,
on n'est pas dans ce monde-là ?
Et dans ce monde
de l'enfermement ?
D'une certaine façon,
- et je vous titille là,
parce que vous êtes musulman, -
est-ce que l'islam
ne participe pas
particulièrement à ça ?
-Vous avez raison...
-Pourquoi l'islamisme ?
-Quand on regarde le monde
qui est le nôtre aujourd'hui,
il est extrêmement fragmenté,
fracturé même,
où la politique ressemble
à du tribalisme, aujourd'hui.
On est dans un monde
qui a pu prononcer
cette phrase exceptionnelle
de faits alternatifs,
comme si, au fond,
rien n'était un fait
si ce n'était pas accepté comme tel
par ma propre tribu politique.
La vérité dépend
de la tribu politique
qui énonce
la proposition en question.
Et d'ailleurs,
ceci n'est pas sans lien
avec ce que nous avions dit
du recul démocratique.
Le recul démocratique
et la fragmentation,
le caractère fracturé
de nos engagements politiques,
et le tribalisme en politique,
tout cela va ensemble.
Dans ce monde des identités,
où on a l'impression
que nous n'avons plus
un espace public commun
où nous échangeons
des arguments.
-Amin Maalouf parlait
des identités malheureuses.
-Il a raison
parce que nous pouvons, au fond,
- et c'est la nature même
de l'espace public, -
nous pouvons différer,
ne pas être d'accord,
en parlant la même langue
et en échangeant des arguments,
en comprenant que nous partageons
au moins les mêmes faits
et que nous avons la même logique.
Les identités empêchent même cela.
Il n'y a plus d'espace public,
si tout ce que je fais,
c'est faire la performance
de ma propre identité,
répéter que mon expérience
est celle d'un homme noir,
que vous ne pouvez pas
la comprendre,
car vous n'en êtes pas un.
Ca veut dire que tout argument
est réduit
à sa plus simple expression.
Tout argument devient un argument
ad hominem.
-Ce qu'on appelle
de l'essentialisme.
-Oui. "Je dis ce que je dis
parce que je suis qui je suis."
"Vous dites ce que vous dites
parce que vous êtes qui vous êtes."
Au fond, nous avons
des discours parallèles
qui vont nourrir
ce tribalisme-là.
Malheureusement,
dans ces affirmations de l'identité,
dans ses enfermements identitaires,
la religion est la chose
la plus facile à mobiliser.
-Un des moteurs, quoi.
-Oui.
La religion est précisément
ce pour quoi on est prêt à mourir.
Vous avez raison de dire
que les religions,
de ce point de vue en général,
peuvent jouer un rôle
d'amplification de ce tribalisme,
de ces identitarismes,
de ces enfermements
dans des particularismes.
Malheureusement,
nous avons vu cela
avec les interprétations
les plus extrémistes de l'islam.
Ceci fait partie
de notre géopolitique, aujourd'hui.
C'est la raison
pour laquelle il faut,
et c'est un travail
que moi-même et d'autres
essayons de mener, évidemment.
-C'est un rôle d'intellectuel.
Rappeler
des interprétations ouvertes
de la religion.
Rappeler que si la religion peut
être le problème,
elle a également
la capacité d'être la solution.
Une religion universaliste,
une religion ouverte,
c'est une religion qui doit pouvoir
accepter le pluralisme.
Et montrer
que la religion
est ouverte au pluralisme,
et que ce qu'il a défini,
pour revenir
à notre philosophe Bergson,
dont nous nous parlions,
c'est son caractère ouvert,
sa capacité à accompagner
l'ouverture constante
de la société.
A société ouverte,
religion dynamique.
Voilà un travail
qu'il est nécessaire,
aujourd'hui, d'effectuer.
Ce qui nous ramène
au cas sénégalais,
dont nous parlions tout à l'heure.
Ces confréries, elles sont
autant d'expressions du soufisme.
Lequel soufisme est précisément
l'interprétation la plus ouverte.
-La plus apaisée.
-La plus apaisée de l'islam
et la plus pluraliste.
Le soufisme, en son essence même,
est acceptation nécessairement
de la différence,
et donc pluralisme.
Le pluralisme,
c'est véritablement
la signification de la tolérance.
-Quelque part dans vos écrits,
j'ai retenu cette phrase,
que vous prêchez,
- pardon, c'est facile, -
pour une reconstruction
de la pensée religieuse.
-Oui.
Sous l'influence d'un auteur
qui m'a beaucoup marqué,
auquel j'ai consacré un livre,
qui est le philosophe indien,
le penseur indien,
poète lui-même, Mohamed Iqbal.
-Mohamed Iqbal,
qui est très critiqué
par un autre écrivain,
pas par un penseur,
mais un écrivain,
aussi d'origine indienne,
qui s'appelle V. S. Naipaul,
qui estime que Iqbal
est pas du tout une référence
à conseiller.
On voit Naipaul à droite, là,
qui est un très grand écrivain,
et Mohamed Iqbal
qui est pakistanais,
je crois.
-Il est père spirituel du Pakistan
parce qu'il a affirmé,
à un moment donné,
dans un de ses écrits,
qu'il fallait penser une autonomie,
au sein du sous-continent indien,
des régions à majorité musulmane.
Ca explique probablement
la raison pour laquelle
Naipaul ne le tient pas
en grande estime.
Mais cela étant,
si nous regardons
la philosophie de Mohamed Iqbal
telle qu'elle s'exprime
dans ses écrits théoriques
et dans sa poésie,
il a exprimé
le meilleur du soufisme.
Il a dit et il a écrit
contre ce qu'il a appelé,
je le cite,
"l'idole de la race
et de la tribu".
Et c'est en cette formule,
par exemple,
que l'on peut voir l'interprétation,
la lecture qu'il a faite
d'un islam qui serait un islam
du pluralisme et de l'ouverture.
De la même manière,
il a également estimé
que l'islam avait eu
une phase de pétrification.
Après une phase d'ouverture,
d'inventivité, de créativité,
où on a vu,
pour parler le langage
de Mao Zedong,
100 écoles s'épanouir,
autant d'écoles juridiques,
il y a eu un moment
de pétrification, dit-il,
de la pensée islamique.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
son ouvrage majeur
en prose
s'est intitulé "Reconstruire
la pensée religieuse de l'islam".
-On dit souvent aujourd'hui
que l'Afrique,
un peu facilement, comme ça,
est le continent du XXIe siècle.
Vous êtes d'accord
ou ce sont des formules
qui ne veulent pas dire
grand-chose ?
-Il y a de la formule, évidemment,
mais il y a une réalité,
qui est d'abord
une réalité démographique.
Les prospectivistes disent
que la démographie, c'est un destin.
Ca veut dire
qu'il faut en tenir compte.
Quand on voit la démographie
aujourd'hui dans le monde,
l'Afrique va avoir
une des démographies
les plus importantes
et les plus jeunes.
Dans deux générations ou... Demain !
-D'accord.
-Finalement.
Ceci est le premier atout
et le premier élément.
-Ca peut être un handicap aussi.
-Oui.
-2 milliards d'individus,
d'ici à 2050.
-Le fait que l'Afrique ait
cette démographie,
ça signifie autant de jeunes
qu'il faut pouvoir...
-Nourrir.
-...transporter,
qu'il faut pouvoir nourrir,
qu'il faut pouvoir instruire,
former, à qui il faut donner
des emplois,
et c'est un casse-tête énorme.
Mais la même démographie
qui est un problème,
est un atout également,
dès que l'on regarde les tendances
et la prospective.
D'autant que c'est un continent
qui a des ressources énormes,
des ressources très importantes.
Donc une Afrique
qui prend aujourd'hui conscience
de sa propre force et qui affirme
sa présence dans le monde.
Il y a peu,
on disait que l'Afrique
ne pesait que moins de 2 %
du commerce mondial,
au fond, que le continent pouvait
disparaître dans l'Atlantique...
-On s'en apercevrait pas.
-Il manquerait à l'humanité,
mais sur le plan des échanges...
Plus personne ne le dit.
C'est la raison pour laquelle
il y a une nouvelle ruée
vers l'Afrique.
Après la ruée des colonisations,
c'est la ruée du partenariat.
Des pays s'intéressent à l'Afrique
et il y a une concurrence
faite aux anciennes
puissances coloniales
qui pensaient être établies
sur le terrain africain.
-C'est pas le cas.
-Ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui.
Donc effectivement, il y a
des raisons objectives de dire
que c'est un continent d'avenir.
De là à dire
que le XXIe siècle lui appartiendra,
là, on retrouve la formule.
-Merci,
Souleymane Bachir Diagne.
Merci beaucoup de cet entretien.
-Merci de votre accueil.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA